This lecture consists of two
parts that deal with two
rather different topics.
In the first part, we look into
an important special case
of a derived distribution
problem.
We start with two independent
random variables with known
distributions and wish to find
the distribution of their sum.
We will see that for either the
discrete or the continuous
case, there is a nice formula
that gives us the answer.
We will develop this formula and
then we will talk a little
bit about a graphical way
of carrying out the
calculations involved.
As we will discuss, this formula
also allows us to
establish the very important
fact that the sum of two
independent, normal random
variables is normal.
In the second part, we introduce
the covariance of
two random variables and the
correlation coefficient.
These are certain quantities
that allow us to quantify the
degree to which two dependent
random variables are related.
For example, a high value of
the correlation coefficient
will indicate a strong
relation between
these random variables.
We will see the basic
mathematical properties of
these quantities and provide
some interpretation.
Later on in this class, we will
see that they play an
important role in the problem
of estimating one random
variable, given the
value of another.